un conductor grabó las imágenes de la
nube negra producida por la explosión
del parque industrial en alemania desde
su teléfono móvil los bomberos
controlaron el incendio después de
cuatro horas la búsqueda de los
desaparecidos continúa tras la
confirmación de al menos un muerto y más
de una docena de heridos los operadores
del parque industrial y el alcalde local
dijeron estar profundamente
entristecidos por la noticia
es una situación muy difícil para el
parque industrial y para nosotros como
operadores nuestro pensamiento está en
los familiares de las víctimas es un día
trágico para leverkusen una ciudad
vinculada al parque industrial y a la
industria química cualquier familia
local podría tener conocidos trabajando
en este lugar
bolt de trump el incidente ocurrió en la
zona de vertedero y de incineración de
residuos lejos de las grandes empresas
químicas como bayer y lanxess sin
embargo el parque químico ubicado en la
ciudad de leverkusen a 15 kilómetros del
norte de colonia es uno de los más
grandes de europa
la explosión advirtió a los residentes
de la zona pero las autoridades
descartaron posibles daños a su salud
producida por el aire la causa de la
explosión está
investigada